if you want to hear the details about
Diana's time and mulberry Hill mental
hospital then stick around to the end of
this video the last several decades of
each bird that a horror icon Michael
Myers half of the 70s Freddy Krueger
slashed his way through the 80's
Ghostface dialed into the 90s and jigsaw
tested movie audiences in the 2000 and
while the tens had no shortage of iconic
horror franchises many of the
antagonists were either invisible
entities or characters not really seen
for most of their respective movies
although she only appeared in one movie
today it's unlike all of the other names
I mentioned I think it's certainly
possible to make the case for Diana
Walter from lights out to be the face of
horror in the time although many people
will probably say penny wise who
technically debuted in the 90s but we've
already covered penny wise here on
horror history so today we're gonna take
a look into the shadows and analyze the
entire story of Diana to fully
understand her journey let's take it
back once more to the 70s for her birth
[Music]
Diana Walter was born in 1971 she
suffered from a rare skin disorder that
made her extremely sensitive to light
like a ginger in July Diana made sure to
keep herself in the shade as much as
possible although she is stated to have
parents it is possible she was adopted
because one article mentions that nobody
knows where she came from of course
there were many stories about her she
was said to be evil and have the
abilities to get inside people's heads
and this seems to be the fate suffered
by her parents or foster parents when
Diana was 13 years old she was found
locked in a basement with her father who
had blown his head off on October 6th
1984 Diana was admitted to mulberry Hill
mental institution doctors there
determined that her condition required
helio therapy a form of treatment where
a person is bathed in full-spectrum
lights usually used to lessen the
effects of diseases like psoriasis
eczema and dermatitis Diana however was
no ordinary patient and began to display
what doctors referred to as a history of
violence during her stay at the
institution the first known incident was
on February 9th 1985 when she assaulted
a patient leaving the person with the
fractured radius and Olman another
incident left a patient with the
transverse radius fracture and a third
attack resulted in a lateral incision on
another individual on June 5th 1986 she
inflicts what appears to be some kind of
room
hey ginger there are many other patients
assaulted at least 13 more incidents
victims of scratching bruising broken
bones and more another incident was
recorded on July 12 and one that took
place in April was especially nasty the
victim was found with arm bite marks and
deep cuts that resulted in having to get
43 stitches inside and out at some point
during her stay Diana met Sophie the
patients in the Helio therapy ward
suffering from some form of mental
illness including extreme depression
Diana when you were taking therefore
your depression am i right because
Sophie's mind was already very weak
Diana easily got into her head and made
her think that they were friends Diana
latched on to Sophie and developed a
tight bond so that she would permanently
ingrain herself into the young girl's
mind taking a step back the relationship
between Diana and Sophie is an allegory
for Sophie's depression they met during
a low point in Sophie's life so if he
did not know where Diana came from and
they became best friends in other words
the depression consumed her life and
like depression Diana came back and hid
Sophie the hardest just when she was
starting to recover this came in the
form of an attack that crushed her left
index and middle fingers she had to be
put in restraints following this
incident and claims to have attacked
Sophie because she was getting better
which of course would have resulted in
her getting healthy and leaving the
institution at this point an
experimental therapy is performed on
Diana involving 1200 watts of
full-spectrum light the treatment caused
her a great deal of pain and convulsion
just like me after every passing day of
no baseball the so-called therapy caused
Diana to just disappear and the doctors
had no choice but to report her death
but to this day there are still varying
accounts on what happened going back to
our analogy therapy causes depression to
disappear for many years diana was gone
but she seemed to exist somewhere in
Sophie's mind seemingly her only
connection to this world during this
time diana is locked in the darkest area
of the house the basement where she
leaves diary messages using fingerprints
on the walls this is another symbol for
depression and mental illness a person
may appear to recover without actually
getting rid of their ailments they can
suppress it push it to the depth of the
back of their mind and go on trying to
live their lives without ever truly
facing it with the problem with this
method is that it can come back stronger
than ever
according to dr. crystal and Salters pet
nulls if you've ever had an intense
thought or feeling that you couldn't
handle in the moment or felt overwhelmed
by and tried to push it away you
experienced emotional suppression for
yourself research shows that it is not
only ineffective in eliminating thoughts
and feelings but it may even worsen the
situation that appears to be exactly
what happens with Sophie in the late 90s
she's married with a daughter named
Rebecca when Diana comes back now in the
form of this somewhat ghost-like
creature when Sophie starts talking to
Diana again it causes her to appear
crazy and her health takes a serious
decline this scares away Rebecca's
father causing him to abandon the family
and diana takes great pride in the idea
of getting stuffy by herself she preys
on loneliness she been social with
anyone coming over Rebecca on the other
hand convinces herself that Diana isn't
real which was easier for her because
none of the other adults in her life
we're gonna believe her about a creepy
shadow lady that only shows up in the
dark I'm gonna tell you something and
nobody ever told me I believe you but
Rebecca eventually leaves her mother as
well and Sofie once again has to get
professional help to get rid of Diana
this time she goes on antidepressants
and talks to a psychiatrist but like
last time Sofie is only able to suppress
her and years later after Sofie
remarries and has another kid diana
rises up once again in southern
california in the modern day diana
starts talking to Sophie once again and
convinces her to feel bad for abandoning
her all of those years ago
Sophie sinks into a deeper depression
than ever before and her family who
never sees Diana early on thinks that
she's going crazy again and talking to
herself
Sophie's new husband Paul well is more
committed than the previous guy and
instead of running he looks into
possible avenues to get her battery for
Diana this would mean going away again
and not wanting to be locked in the
basement for a third time Diana shows up
at Paul's work to try to deter him and
she ends up scaring one of his employees
a woman named Esther before eventually
attacking Paul breaking his bones and
clawing his eyes out
Paul represented Sophie's support line
so taking him out was a big win for
Diana
I miss your dad he made me feel strong
the loss as you can imagine did not help
with her condition which was only
worsened by the fact that she's off her
medication and she refuses to see a
therapist diana appears with increasing
frequency to talk to Sophie each night
this time wanting to get a strong hold
over her mind as not to be repressed and
locked away again from the point of view
of Sophie's son Martin his mom is
talking to herself because she's not
taking her medication until one night
when he sees Diana in the closet this
represents the lack of coping skills in
a patient of mental illness which can
lead to the entire family being affected
diana tries to break into martin's room
and he's unable to get any sleep all
night it's wanting to isolate her victim
further and diana goes after martin as
he stays over the next night with his
half-sister rebecca seeing her child the
only person she had left leave her
causes a lot of distress for Sophie
which makes Diana even more powerful she
scratches her name into the floor in
Rebecca's apartment but can't get to her
before she's able to turn the lights
back on
Martin protects himself by sleeping in
the bathtub with a flashlight the reason
that she's not able to go into the light
may be related to the slang term often
associated with the depression you may
hear that a depressed person is in a
dark place right now or that their mind
went to a dark place there's also
evidence that sunlight is something that
can help fight depression in a journal
written by RN Rachel Moll it has
explained that exposure to sunlight is
thought to increase the brains release
of a hormone called serotonin serotonin
is associated with boosting mood and
helping a person feel calm and focused
at night's darker lighting it figures
the brain to make another hormone called
melatonin this hormone is responsible
for helping you sleep this could explain
why Martin who is constantly trying to
keep himself in the light to avoid Diana
is unable to get any sleep at night
outside of the fact that the little dude
is just freakin terrified all the time
the next day Rebecca searches the house
for clues and diana locks her inside of
her old room
[Applause]
another symbol of light versus shadow
can be seen that afternoon when Martin
and Sophie returned to the house with
some groceries sophie recommends that
the three of them watch a movie implying
that diana will be there as much as i
love the idea of this monster just
chilling on the couch much and down some
popcorn martin suggests that maybe just
him and his mom check out the movie you
can tell that sophie is being
manipulated as she responds with her
standing in the shade while martin
remains in the sunlight mom how about
you me night okay we'll see during the
movie Diana comes for Martin and when he
runs she attacked Sophie this represents
Sophie's condition getting so bad it's
about to cause hurts to her own son so
he flees back to Rebecca's place where
Diana tries to pull him under the bed
every little kids worst nightmare they
all stay over at the house and sophie
starts to realize that her illness is
getting the better of her again not
wanting diana to find out that she's
seeking help she slips a note to her
daughter before going to bed so if you
realized that she was about to have a
manic episode and this is conveyed in
the movie by diana completely cutting
off power to the house as with anyone
close to someone suffering from
depression it is those closest to them
that are impacted first and diana goes
after martin who protects himself using
a candle he escapes to get help from
rebecca but diana locks the two of them
in the basement and goes after Rebecca's
boyfriend Brent who's also staying in
the house with them but I just hadn't
really mentioned him yet because he
hasn't come up yet but he's the man he
really is he ends up going to the cops
to get help next Diana attacks her hosts
Sophie because she sees her going for a
bottle of antidepressants since Sophie
is Diana's only tide a reality she must
be left alive but she is knocked out in
the bedroom floor diana targets rebecca
and martin but the cops show up and she
takes out one of them as well in the end
rebecca does which he was unable to do
as a child and stands up for her mother
against her oppressor
but in the end sophie realizes that her
disease is hurting the ones that she
loves the most and like many victims of
mental illness and real life she puts an
end to it in the most tragic way
possible because she believes that the
only way to destroy diana is to
eliminate herself because of her
connection to Sophie's mind diana is a
scary horror movie antagonist in more
ways than one in particular i think it's
her tendency to keep herself hidden in
the shadow
that really makes this character hit
differently because this is what caused
the people around Sophie to not realize
that she was being haunted by Diana just
like depression in real life where the
symptoms don't always manifest
themselves in very obvious ways I know
times are tough right now for a lot of
people and it's not easy to get into the
sunlight right now while we're all
foreign teaming ourselves inside so if
you or someone you know is struggling
I'll leave some resources in the
description remember to subscribe to see
ZZZ world for new Horrors every week
bring that DEATH BATTLE for
notifications and I'll see you in the
next one assuming we stay inside
[Music]